my name is olivia tahi i'm 30 years old
i'm a film director and i make
approximately 80 000 a year i currently
work at a video production company here
in colorado called mightier i do a range
of things sometimes i'm directing
sometimes i'm editing other times i'm
creating storyboards or scripts or just
coming up with concepts for clients and
then a lot of it is just meeting with
clients talking to them making sure
everything's on track and that we're
getting their vision right yeah i think
when you're in a small business you kind
of have to wear
a ton of hats it's not
uh
one of those jobs where everything is
very siloed and you have just one job
and that's what you have to focus on i
think i'm lucky in that i get to touch a
lot of things at work because if i can
set up the
storyboard for success that way when i'm
on set later i you know i'm so grateful
to the olivia of two months ago where i
set myself up for success um and then
you know going into post-production as
well making sure i'm slating in properly
so just being thorough at every stage
because there's a very good chance i'll
have to deal with it later i have had 10
internships and i have been working in
this industry for 10 years and this is
now my first full paying job where i
actually have benefits and i know when
my next paycheck is going to come in
i
cannot even tell you the amount of
thankless grubby jobs i have done to get
to where i am now and i think it's
important to remember that whoever
you're working for or if you're just
starting out the person who's maybe in
charge of your project has also paid
those same dues
the people who might be a little higher
up than you have had a lot of experience
doing these things
and it's important to just learn from
them and instead of talking so much just
remember to listen first and foremost
my long-term goals are to get signed
with a larger production company where i
am
just working whenever i win a bid
and that would mean
probably working less hours but the
stakes are so much higher because that's
maybe my only job for the month
and then
my goal
is to have a job like that where i may
be working one out of every four weeks a
month that lets me focus on my own
projects my ultimate plan is to take all
of these work opportunities and
positions
uh to get better at being a director and
ultimately create my first feature film
if you are interested in being a film
director then
my first piece of advice is going to be
to just shoot just shoot your own movies
there is no reason why you can't make a
film with the tools that you have there
are so many wonderful films now being
shot on an iphone and if you have an
iphone or a smartphone that means that
you have what it takes equipment wise to
make a feature film so
grab your friends you know
find a weekend and just make stuff
happen because
you
won't learn as much about directing from
a book or from a website as you will
than just being on a shoot and trying to
make your dream come true i will say
some of the pitfalls though are that
it's hard to get validation it's hard to
get recognition because there are so
many other filmmakers out there and you
really just have to find your own voice
in the beginning you might be trying to
copy other artists and like that's
understandable because you're trying to
figure out your style but i would say
find your voice find the movie that you
want to watch and make sure that you're
the one who makes it